foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and over till we forget that it's a
lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will show you all the new photos
from the set of House of the dragon's
second season now if you haven't read
George R Martin's Fire and Blood I would
recommend shutting off this video if you
don't want to know what happens in the
next season these photos will reveal
some of the biggest moments from the
second season let's dive into all of
House of the dragon's new images now
that I've gave you a fair warning now as
you all know the dance of the Dragons
has more or less officially begun after
aemon and his massive Dragon vagar
devoured Lou carries valerion and his
little dragon RX we all saw this
incredible moment happen at the end of
the first season and as you can imagine
that devastating event will send
shockwaves throughout Westeros the death
of lucarius and his Dragon will be felt
all over the Seven Kingdoms now if you
haven't read fire in blood or seen some
of my other videos then you will learn
Daemon reacts to the death of lucari's
almost immediately we saw him deliver
the heartbreaking news to reniera at the
end of the first season in George RR
Martin's Fire and Blood Daemon isn't on
Dragonstone with rhaenyra when that
happens but he does send her a raven
right away in that letter to rhaenyra he
Demands a son for a son and an eye for
an eye he wants revenge in the worst way
imaginable what Daemon has done next
leads to one of the most Savage moments
in all of A Song of Ice and Fire now for
those of you who don't know Daemon has
his lady masaria find some men who can
go into the red keep at night and strike
against aegon and Helena's children
history remembers them only as blood and
cheese
one night Queen Helena entered the Royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand they told her that adet was owed a
son for a son blood and cheese demanded
she choose which son would be ripped
from her forever
Queen Helena pleaded with the man to
kill her instead but they refused
weeping Helena named her younger son
Melo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
perhaps because the older boy was King
aegon's first born son and heir
you hear that little boy she's whispered
to the younger son your mama wants you
dead then blood struck off the older
boy's head with a single blow when the
guards burst in they found Queen Helena
still screaming clasping her dead son's
body to her mad with grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
either aegon or anira could live at the
end but not both now the reason why I
showed you that video is because it
leads right into the new photos from the
set of House of the dragon's second
season these new photos show what is
most likely the funeral of little
Johari's Targaryen not only does it say
it on the little note but we can also
see the Royal Carriage as well the
funeral procession will go through the
streets of King's Landing we will most
likely see aegon and his sister wife
Elena riding in the wagon along with
their dead son you can see all the
horses lined up along the street as well
everyone in this city will be out here
as they go by now these photos also
reveal another major moment from this
season I think the blood and cheese
scene will break the internet in itself
but this other scene will shock everyone
as well in this other photo we see
another massive wagon that has something
hitting underneath it well according to
some sources who were there on set that
day they say this wagon will be holding
the head of melees the Dragon of
rainey's Targaryen as you all know the
dragons are made up entirely of computer
generated images however this wagon is
holding a massive blue foam head that
will stand in for melees which they will
later fix with CGI now if any of you are
wondering how melees dies the scene from
the history in lore video might give you
a good idea had sent not an army but her
former Mother by Laura rames and her
Dragon males as her ancestor had done at
the Field of Fire rhaenys gleefully
began to incinerate sir Christian's Army
but aegon had set a trap at rhaenys had
flown right into it as rainys and melees
blanketed sir Christian's troops and
dragonflame two other dragons Rose into
the sky
and aegon himself from a gleaming
Sunfire
to her credit Raney didn't flee
Dragon Fort dragons and his second son
blossomed in the sky aegon in his
brother aemon might defeat Raines and
her Dragon melees but that Victory will
come at a cost the second season of
House of the Dragon will be filled with
a lot of amazing moments whether they're
seen as highs or lows for the blacks or
the greens as you can imagine all hell
is about to break loose in Westeros now
that the dance of the Dragons has
officially begun let me know what you
think about all these new photos down
below what scene are you looking forward
to most and what scene are you dreading
the most leave me your thoughts about
all this new information as always I
have to thank all of you for watching
another video I hope everyone has a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
now for those of you who don't know the
writers for the Duncan egg series are on
strike as are many other writers from
many other shows in Los Angeles and
around the United States now the good
news is these writers will eventually be
able to get back to work although we
don't know exactly how long this strike
will last and as long as the writers are
on strike they will not be able to work
on the Duncan egg show that new series
will remain on Ice until they're able to
resolve the issue now let me show you
what George R Martin said so you know
exactly what's happening behind the
scenes he said the writer strike is on
no one wanted this no writer with an
ounce of sense anyway but the producers
and the studios and the networks and the
streamers gave us no choice The Guild
negotiated right up until the final
deadline on May the 1st but it takes two
to tango in the waning hours of May 1st
The Writers Guild of America declared a
strike there are pickets in front of
every Studio Lot in soundstage in Los
Angeles and many in other cities as well
get used to them I expect they will be
there for a long time I am not in Los
Angeles so I cannot walk the line as I
did back in 1988 but I want to go on
record with my full and complete and
unequivocal support of my guild now how
long will the strike last no idea maybe
the members will come to their census
tomorrow and offer some meaningful
concessions and the whole thing can be
wrapped up next week I would not bet the
ranch on that however I have been
through several of these since I first
started writing for television in film
back in 1986 the 1988 strike the first
one I was a part of lasted 22 weeks the
longest in Hollywood history the
2007-2008 strike the most recent went on
for 100 days this one might go on for
longer the issues are more significant
ishma and I have never seen the guild so
United as it is right now writer strikes
tend to be longer than other labor
actions that's the nature of the Beast
everyone has seen this storm coming a
long way off and accordingly Studios and
streamers and networks have been
stockpiling scripts for months as of May
the second the pens are down and the
computer screens have gone dark all
across Hollywood but production will
continue so long as there are scripts to
shoot now many of you will be wondering
rightfully about the impact of the
strike on my own shows the writer's room
on a night of the Seven Kingdoms the
Hedge Knight has closed down for the
duration Ira Parker and his incredible
staff of young talents are on the picket
lines across the ocean the second season
of House of the Dragons started filming
April 11th and will continue in London
and Wales the scripts for the eight
season two episodes were all finished
months ago long before the strike began
every episode had already gone through
four or five drafts and numerous rounds
of revisions to address HBO's notes my
notes budget concerns and Etc there will
be no further revisions the writers have
done their jobs the rest is in the hands
of the directors cast and crew and of
course the dragons now some of you I
fear might be having anxiety attacks
just now on the mistaken assumption that
the strike of affects the Winds of
Winter you can relax the wga is a union
of film and television writers it has
nothing to do with novels short stories
or any other forms of fiction nor comic
books and graphic novels nor stage plays
nor the editing of Collections and
anthologies and the ones of winter
continues to be my number one Focus now
let's be honest here folks he's nowhere
near ready to release the wins of winter
anyway regardless if the strike had
affected his own writing or not
unfortunately as I said before it has
affected HBO's new Game of Thrones
series about Duncan egg those writers
are no longer working on the show at
least for now the good news is House of
the Dragon has already started filming
so we don't have to worry about the
strike slowing down that show all of its
episodes were already written many
months ago hopefully this writer strike
will get settled soon that way it
doesn't affect House of the dragon's
third season as you saw George RR Martin
fears this might be the longest strike
in Hollywood's history so although it
hasn't affected how also the dragon's
second season it very well could affect
its third season depending on how long
it does last for now we will just have
to wait and see how everything does
unfold now it is hard to say how this
might affect the show about Jon Snow now
if you remember George R Martin revealed
kit Harrington had his own writers well
over six months ago if that's the case
they might have already wrote their
first season or at the very least a
pilot episode so the strike might not
have any effect on the series about Jon
Snow assuming they are still working on
that show its status is still unknown as
of right now as always I will make sure
to give you updates whenever something
significant happens leave me some of
your thoughts down below once again I
have to thank all of you for watching
another video I hope all of you have a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign